headguard
[Music]
wake up
that's right everybody today i'm
explaining multiverse theory to my dog
yeah are you awake
yeah
so this is not going to be an
educational video do not take what i say
as fact
it's just a way for me to see if i
understand it then i should at least be
able to explain it right okay
and i think it's really freaking cool so
hopefully this will spark some interest
for other people rather than me saying
okay this is how it is don't do that
don't listen to me i'm just explaining
to my dog
but you know we're all familiar with
multiverse theory we've all heard about
it in some sort of sci-fi movie or
regular movie
in general they always come up everyone
knows about it but i want to understand
how does it actually work what's the
actual idea
behind it being theoretically possible
so i found the experience of trying to
understand multiverse theory extremely
annoying
because what would happen was new terms
that i you know i have no base knowledge
of these things but new terms would
always come up while trying to
understand something so i have to look
up what that means and while looking up
what that means another term comes up
and i have to look up what that means
and then when i look up what that means
another time comes up and then i have to
look up what that means and i'm just
getting further and further and further
away from actually understanding
anything
but that ends now the goal of this video
it might not be the most perfect
explanation but i want anyone to watch
this and trying to understand as well
that's my goal we're gonna keep this
simple baby and we're gonna keep this
crystal clear so even my dumb dog edgar
understands you are watching this video
now but in the video if you make it
through you're going to be like huh i
get it i get multiverse theory that's
what we're doing now i said that i would
got really frustrated but in reality a
lot of these things that annoyed me at
first turn out to be really really cool
concepts
and ideas that i actually found really
really interesting so trying to
understand multiverse theory and
and all that has actually been really
really fun i love doing this and this
video is more of me being excited and
wanted to talk about it so take it as
that again not an instructional video
so
multiverse theory is generally as far as
i understand divided into four levels so
there's level one level two layer three
level four and i don't think there's a
specific reason to why they're called
levels it's not like you have to level
go from one level to another it's just a
way to separate all these different
ideas
so we're gonna start off with level one
and i'm gonna stop at level three but
they're amazing and it's super
fascinating so let's start off with
level one level one you're probably
already familiar with in some sense it's
the first one i have ever heard about
and it's the idea that our universe or
if there's infinite universe or infinite
space since you exist by mere chance if
a space out there is infinite then by
mere probability sheer probability there
will have to be another one of you
eventually out there it's sort of
picturing that our universe is a random
structure of particles that just happen
to be and it's just a matter of okay
well how far would you have to then
travel
for the probability of another same set
of uh particles uh being structured in
the same sense i remember hearing about
this multiverse theory in uh i don't
know if you've seen this movie the beach
where leo is like making kind of let's
see what he says
i mean there are infinite worlds out
there you know
where anything you want to happen
does happen
but should you know something
this is just the kind of pretentious
birds that americans always say to
french girls
so they can sleep with them
shut up babe it's cool it's cool right
it's cool it's cool to imagine the idea
that another version of you is out there
right again
[Music]
it's also kind of hopeful in a way you
know if things are here at least in
another universe someone else is doing
way better
we can only hope i'm in the good
universe right
you're having a great time weren't you
yeah do you understand
so this is generally seen as a least
controversial idea of a multiverse so
picturing space and how big it is is
something i wasn't really familiar with
apparently the way we distinguish it it
seems like i just didn't pay attention
in school at all but apparently the way
we distinguish our universe is what we
call our observable universe and it's
basically how far light has traveled
since big bang anything beyond that we
can't see because light hasn't reached
those uh areas yet and it's it spans 42
billion light years
so even though you try and imagine
infinite space to me that makes more
sense that the universe is infinite
because if it's finite then what the f
is beyond the edge of the finite
is is there just a sign that says hey
space ends here stop here can't go
further but i guess in a sense we do
have that with our observable universe
but we do imagine that whatever is
outside our observable universe
is just like space
inside our universe cool
great uh max actually did a really cool
experiment max tag mike then i think
he's the one that categorized multiverse
theory into these levels
and he actually did a calculation to see
okay if we are just random particle
structure
how far would we then have to travel to
reach another multiverse in our
identical parallel universe rather sorry
uh and he came up with the number 10 to
the 10
to the then raised 118.
is that meters it doesn't sound that far
right you imagine that four times 10 to
raise our universe is 4
x 10 to raise 26. that doesn't sound far
at all that's 14 billion in light years
you try and imagine that number
you can't you just can't possibly even
picture how far that is but it is kind
of cool that you can imagine how far to
travel for another universe that's a
good picture to draw for our observable
universe moving on everyone's satisfied
with multi layer one multiverse theory
yeah random it's kind of weird to
imagine that you exist by sheer
probability right i don't like the
thought that much to be honest
so universe big
anything can happen that's basically
your level one multiverse oh your tongue
is out now you're ready for multiverse
level two i think this is where it gets
really uh interesting so level two uses
uh
this fantastic discovery that i had
never heard about i wonder if now that
probably a lot of you who are younger
than me are learning about this in
school but it's a cosmic microwave
background
which is basically
a sort of map of our universe it's the
oldest radiation that exists in our
universe and they dated it back to 380
000 years
after the big bang so discovering this
cosmic microwave background also it's a
great proof for that the big bang did
happen even though there are already uh
many things evidence for it okay then
we're not here to debate that but the
cosmic microwave background is the sort
of thing that just gives a lot of
information about our universe but it
also gave us information that
sort of makes things difficult to
understand uh big bang
you're so cute look at you
so while examining the cosmic microwave
background scientists discovered two
fatal flaws or or big problems that are
very perplexing
and the first one is the horizon problem
and i don't know i just think this is so
interesting uh
so if you look at the cosmic microwave
background and you take look at two
opposite ends of it that you're looking
at two opposite ends of the universe
and what p what they realized was that
these two
uh different ends of the universe are
way too uniform by the decimal to the
decimal to decimal i don't know how to
express it but
they are so uniform that they would have
had to been in contact at some point
it's kind of like how you mix two fluids
uh together right you mix g fuel with
powder
eventually it finds a uniform taste
this is the greatest example i've ever
done
can you sit still i'm trying to explain
to you so this is the horizon problem
but the real problem about this is that
to travel in between them they are so
far away that it would take longer to
travel between them than the universe
have ever existed so theoretically it's
impossible for these to be that far
apart so how can two pieces of the
universe be so uniform alike
that they would have have to been closed
at some point and be so far away
focus so that's one issue the other
issue is the flatness problem which i
really struggle with and i think i've
learned everything about it and at the
end of the day all you really have to
understand is the universe is really
flat
in fact it's so flat that it's puzzling
just how flat it is that's the flatness
problem and i don't want to know i don't
know how much detail i should get into
this it's one of those things where i
just went around in circles i'm like
what the what does flat mean how can the
universe be flat i don't really
understand any of these i don't know
what the best way to explain it either
there's a bun hello
hello
so i guess all you need to know in
scientific terms without complicating
things too much there's something called
the density perimeter it's this omega
sign that you see and it sort of helps
us determine what the shape of the
universe is the density perimeter is
based on i think gravity and mass the
density perimeter is the ratio of the
average density of matter and energy in
the universe to the critical density oh
thank you i totally understand what that
means
to be honest the math behind it we're
not gonna understand so it doesn't
really matter what you do have to
understand is that if this density
perimeter is bigger than one the
universe shape will be a sphere like if
it's smaller than one the shape of the
universe uh will be bent like a sh
i don't know what it's called and if
this is one it's flat universes it means
universe is flat so i gotta be honest
i'm not 100 sure i understand this okay
but they draw this example when with the
triangles right if you add up all the
angles of the triangle and it's uh
180 degrees then that means
it's flat right if it's bigger or
smaller then that means the universe
have these two shapes and i suppose
you can do that with it with a c and b
data of picking points that are very far
away in the universe and so to tell if
the angles add up does that make sense
i'm not i gotta be honest i'm not
entirely sure if that that's exactly how
they do it but that makes sense in my
head at least because things can appear
to us as flat like this picture d here
even though they are
a sphere so we need data that are really
far away and i suppose you can do that
with the cosmic microwave background
because it spans a maps our universe but
the problem is i suppose what they found
is that the universe is
super flat uh what would have been cool
if the universe wasn't flat is that we
could actually calculate the size
because we would know the curvature
and by that logic you can then calculate
the size of the universe so the thing
about this density perimeter is by when
time passes it naturally curves
okay that's all you need to know really
from what i've all said we have this way
of measuring
the curve of the universe and naturally
the more time passes the more it curves
and if you imagine from the point of big
bang to the size that the universe is
now the preciseness of
if this was completely flat the
preciseness of that in the beginning
from what i understand just is too
precise it just seems so
unlikely
that we would find ourselves in this
flat universe with big bang in mind
right i hope i make sense here i wish i
could be like any questions because i
don't really get it either so help me
but i think in reality all we need to
know here is that there's a
the horizon problem two different parts
of the universe are way too like and the
flatness problem which is that the
universe is too freaking flat dude it's
too flat my dude so flat dude in comes
to explain this inflation theory and it
proposes that the universe rapidly i
don't know if rapidly even remotely
begins to explain just how fast
inflation happened it means that the
universe expanded faster than the speed
of light from being the most
smallest thing we could ever
observe to the size of our
observable universe in a matter of a
fraction of a second even fraction of a
fraction of a second our universe had
this incredible unbelievable
exponential growth in such a small
period of time i had never heard of
inflation theory before and
in the beginning it was just really
confusing because you've never heard
about it right what the [ __ ] what is
this cosmic inflation she did maybe they
teach kids this in school now but uh
here's the cosmic microwave background
here's where inflation happened so just
a tiny portion of our time span in the
universe inflation in imagine instead of
the big bang
imagine the big
a big
i don't know how to explain it but i
think the cool thing about inflation is
that you know you're taught that nothing
can travel faster than the speed of
light in school right but it kind of
makes sense that space itself can expand
as fast as he wants there's no rules on
space
being being bigger this is what objects
in space can travel that is the
limitation so
uh this inflation theory doesn't break
any laws of physics and conservation
with energy or anything like that and
alan guth who came up with this theory
explains it that we normally look at
gravity as some sort of attraction
with objects interstellar objects you
know
attracting and swinging each other
around but gravitation can also be
repulsion so what he says is that the
universe was uniform they had the
uniformity before inflation took place
and uh it was flat before inflation took
place which makes sense it would make
way more sense that in the beginning it
was flat anyway
and then from this tiny tiny universe
this is so weird to think about it then
inflated to the observable universe that
we have today and it sounds sort of
fanatical and crazy and i kind of don't
even know if i believe it to be 100
honest but there has been evidence of
the inflation theory with the quantum
fluctuation ripples or some [ __ ] like
that i don't really get it i'm not
getting into that
there's evidence of inflation in while
monitoring the cmb is basically all i'm
gonna say about it and it sort of
beautifully explains these two problems
uh inflation theory also creates the
reason why i'm making this video to talk
about multiverse theory it creates a
problem which is the fact that it once
inflation starts or almost all version
that explains inflation eventually leads
to that there's no reason that inflation
should stop and here's where i get
honestly i get kind of confused and i'm
gonna try my best to explain the way i
understand if anyone would help me in
the comments i would love it
so from what i gather
is that this gravitational repulsion
comes from
a certain state of mass and this mass is
very is unstable and it can decay
randomly like a radioactive substance or
something like that so it starts
decaying but by the time it has decayed
in certain patches
it has already increased in size larger
than itself so this decaying mass is
like a local big bang which means that
our big bang is one out of infinite big
bangs inflation is just
oh no
dick
big bang
hello i'm explaining this inflation okay
you're right in this [ __ ]
keeps going
inflation fix your freight
are you asleep
what is this video
why did i
oh god
okay
anyway i think what's cool about
inflation or internal inflation is that
it's scientists looking at
how universes are created uh what
happens before apparently this is the
level two multiverse and how it's made
and
the other ones could even defy not defy
our laws of physics but they could have
different laws of physics based on how
their universe is created uh there's a
bunch of details on this that it gets
way too complicated for me to understand
but the general principle is that the
problem with inflation theory is well
accepted and well
understood but if you accept inflation
you also kind of have to accept eternal
inflation and if you accept eternally
fresh inflation since something is
eternal and can eventually lead to a big
bang
that means it's infinite big bangs uh i
read somewhere that stephen hawkins like
a couple years ago in is one of his last
i didn't really read into it but i think
he was disputing this idea of eternal
inflation and it's still
a more controversial piece of multiverse
theory than the first one for example
but to summarize multiverse level 2
inflation
the big
never stop
keep making another big bang
that's all you got to know baby you
understand great now we're going to
level 3 edgar and holy [ __ ] okay level
three blew my [ __ ] mind okay
it's so weird and so awesome and i don't
believe it i don't believe it here so to
understand level three multiverse you
have to understand a little bit of
quantum physics which i don't understand
a famous nobel prize physicist said that
if you think you understand quantum
physics you don't understand quantum
physics which is just a play of of
making you understand just how weird
quantum physics is but all you need to
know really is that quantum physics is
describing the smallest parts of our
universe atoms electrons pro uh protons
yeah protons molecules and whatnot
basically what creates everything around
us right our building blocks of our
universe and as far as i understand
in quantum physics you describe things
with as waves
and in comes this wave function okay to
me this is really weird and no one i
felt like someone just skipped like 50
parts of something so you're telling me
we can't depict an electron as a
particle but we depict it as a wave what
the does that mean so this wave function
is a mathematical function to describe
the probability of where we can find an
electron for example or a quantum
particle nothing is precise when you're
talking these tiny baby
baby baby baby tiny
small things so we have to use this
probability wave function
right that makes sense to me but what we
can do is use this wave function to get
fairly accurate results even though it
is probability but from what i
understand is that we don't know if the
wave function is real because no one's
ever seen it
it's just a mathematical way to describe
an electron and they did an experiment
on it that is mentioned apparently all
the time to the point where people are
sick of hearing about this experiment
but i totally understand because this is
this experiment the double slit
experiment probably the strangest thing
i have ever heard about and i can't
believe i've never heard about it and if
you've never heard about it what a
pleasure it is for me to to explain it
to you because it's the weirdest [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard it's so weird so i
actually do remember in school learning
about waves and lights light particles a
little bit so i looked it up so thomas
young in the 1800s was trying to
determine light okay what is light is it
a particle is it a wave apparently there
was a whole dispute between
newton and this guy they butted heads no
it's a light is a particle no light acts
like a wave
right
so thomas young did an experiment where
he shone a light through a slit and on
the back wall of where he shone the
light an interference pattern showed up
and an interference patterns can only
really occur if
waves are interfering with each other i
don't know how to explain this better
than just showing a picture so you have
light waves they pass through this
barrier
and then it's kind of like water waves i
guess
two drops in water they both interfere
with each other and it creates this sort
of striped pattern at the wall you
probably know about this in scope
because for some reason i remember this
in school but all you really need to
know is that the light weight passes
through both of these slits it
interferes with each other and it
creates this pattern and this this can
only really occur since it's a wave and
it passes through both of the slits at
the same time okay that's all you need
to understand here so thomas young
observed this and was like ah
light it's waves got him got him i
proved it later on what einstein
realized was that no actually what the
[ __ ] light can be both particles and
waves i remember learning this i was
like okay sure
think about it how can something be two
things at the same time it makes no
freaking sense so
what these [ __ ] did
is they did an experiment on it and they
should never have done this experiment
i'm joking but it just it's sort of like
testing a paradox you know how can
things be two two things at the same
time and i think that's the thing with
quantum physics is that it just doesn't
make sense like that an electron can be
in an excited state and in a low energy
state or whatever it's called at the
same time quantum particles can can be
two things at the same time and that's
just a weird thing to try and wrap your
head around so they actually tested this
which i think i don't know it just blows
my mind with the double slit experiment
and if you already heard about it yeah
roll your eyes whatever you heard about
a thousand times good for you but uh
basically what they did is they i don't
know how because they must have been
extremely tiny right they did this
double slit experiment but they did it
with electrons and electrons particle
right but we describe it as a wave
function so now we're going to find out
what is an electron is it a wave is it a
particle
because this wave function has been so
far an excellent way to describe an
electron uh but now we will see in
reality so if you picture this double
slit experiment what you imagine will
happen when you shoot let's say these
dots aren't electrons let's say they are
a bunch of
eggs you're throwing eggs
through two slits in a wall and you
expect to find the eggs smashed on the
wall in this type of pattern not in the
middle because it's covered up in the
middle this pattern makes sense throw
egg they hit the hit the wall
okay what happened however with the
electrons is that it created this
interference pattern where we actually
have eggs in the middle or electrons
rather which is weird that shouldn't
happen
unless electrons acts like a wave so as
far as i understand when the electron
hits the wall and when you see it on the
wall that means that the wave function
it has collapsed so the electron no
longer acts like a wave but has now
become a particle and that's why you see
it at the back of the wall does that
make sense it's sort of imagining that
ignore these dots here and imagine a
wave it's a wave it's a wave electron is
a wave and then it hits the wall it's a
particle that's the wave function
collapsing because when they did the
test the electron acts like a wave
passing through the thing otherwise they
wouldn't be able to make this pattern
it's a wave it's a wave it's a wave its
way hits the wall wave function
collapses it's a particle does that make
sense i think i explained that pretty
well yeah
yeah
so here's what that looked like right
but what then you could say is okay well
maybe they're just shooting you know
they're beautiful okay i'm throwing them
just like [ __ ] crazy or particles so
what you could argue is that well the
only way for this to happen is if an
electron passes through
one electron passes through both the
slits at the same time how can one
object be in two places at the same time
don't make sense it don't make sense
it's dumb
i don't even want to think about it so
the theory was that okay well it you
know you're shooting a bunch of electro
electrons through you know they're
probably interfering with each other
okay they're not passing through at the
same time time you dummy they're just
interfering with each other creating
this pattern so what they did with this
experiment which is really crazy is that
they shot them really slow like
electron
electrons so there's no way that two
electrons could interfere with each
other guess what the interference
pattern still showed up
boom
crazy right this is [ __ ] crazy this
is some sci-fi [ __ ]
how did that happen guess what it gets
so weird i can't i don't even want to
say it so what they did was okay well
all right cool how does that happen
i'm sure this is how the scientist said
it
let's you know what let's add an
observer let's add a light that detects
which one of these slit the electron is
passing through so we can understand
what the [ __ ] is happening here how is
this electron acting like a wave we're
going to add an observer and we're
finally going to understand how can this
electron act like a wave and be a
particle at the same time we're going to
have the proof we're going to get it now
we're going to get that stupid electron
what happened it's a particle now you
had an observer the electron acted like
a particle that's just [ __ ] dumb
that's just so dumb quantum physics is
so [ __ ] dumb how
so just by adding an observer to an
electron the wave function collapsed as
soon as it was observed as opposed to
when it hits the wall so adding an
observer to an electron collapses the
wave function basically an electron acts
differently depending if it's being
observed or not what
what i guess it is a bit of a fallacy to
assume that an observer is something
passive because when you're looking at
things at such a small level just by
saying okay i'm just looking at you i'm
not doing anything you're still in a way
interacting with it by observing with
with the electron i think at least i'm
not sure if that's true or not but that
makes sense in my head
when you say an observer to an electron
it kind of makes it go away well they
shouldn't change i'm just looking at it
what is it an anime school girl being
shy come on what are you away with a
particle i don't get this [ __ ] so you
know why does the wave function collapse
when it's being observed and there's a
lot of theories behind this and there's
probably better ones and i didn't look
into all of them but the reason i'm
making this video is to talk about
multiverse theory and one of the
ways to explain and it you know as crazy
as it sounds a way to actually explain
why the wave function collapses is to
look into multiverse and
it says that quantum physics doesn't
apply to just one universe but many
multiverses the electrons is
to describe the wave function is in all
of these spots at the same time
but once we observe it we know which
universe we are in and that's when the
wave function collapses so you don't
know which universe you are in until
you observe it or make the measurement
so each universe has a copy of each
particle does that make sense i think it
doesn't make sense it shouldn't make
sense
so you probably heard about the
schrodinger cat experiment where with
exact same principle where you have a
radioactive material that randomly
decays so by probability of quantum
physics the cat inside a box will die or
live depending on
this random chance of probability but we
don't know the outcome until it's being
observed in the same form of of it's
sort of a way to put this
collapse of the wave function to our
scale
where we don't know it's two things at
the same time until we observe it an
electron is a wave and a particle until
we observe it the schrodinger cat is
both alive and dead at the same time and
is theoretically possible until we
observe it so way to explain this and i
think it's an easier way to understand
multiverse is that the cat lives in one
universe the cat dies in another
universe and we don't know which
universe we are in
until we look inside the box it's the
same sort of principle so this sort of
opens up the door that
our universe is constantly being split
we're splitting our universes depending
on and creating infinite copies of
infinite outcomes and it opens up the
idea that anything that is possible
within the realms of physics is possible
so
there's another universe where uh i am
still the number one subscribed youtuber
there's another universe where i'm still
making hot dogs like i did uh how many
years ago there's another universe where
i just um
decided to finish
university i don't know all these sort
of you know roadblocks that you can
imagine with your own life that each of
these possibilities and each of these
universe
exists according to the many worlds
theory that explains the quantum wave
function collapse
42 minutes time will cut it down i hope
i did a good job i don't think i did but
i tried my best i find this so
fascinating dude why would you want to
believe in all these other sh that
people make up about you know dumb
right there's so much cool stuff that we
can
theoretically think about
about our universe and i think uh what's
fun about this is uh not just
understanding that it's possible but i'm
just kind of at least in some matter
obviously we don't know the math that i
don't at least but in some capacity
understanding how it works to me this is
fascinating and i i just had a lot of
fun uh collecting all this information
for myself and i just wanted to share it
with you guys basically so that's what
this video is if you enjoyed it let me
know smash like subscribe i really
appreciate it and i'll see in the next
one
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes are emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this